uh on real bros one of the story lines
was
xander cheating on his wife with his
motorcycle i mean
he's like he's like cleaning the exhaust
pipe and she comes and she's like
what is going on what it looks like and
then
and then later she's in the car driving
to her bachelorette party and she's like
looking at the bikes instagram and
they're like molly stop looking at the
instagram
i'm sorry i just can't get it out of my
head and then she starts comparing
herself to the bike
and she's like i'm sure i could be like
louder oh my god
oh my god dude you know what's so [ __ ]
man speaking of real bros is like
because of quarantine and how much like
i don't have the same perception of
media
that we used to have like i feel like
you know before we watch like a show or
something and i remember
every single moment i can't remember
[ __ ] from real bros
or like yeah any show i've watched i
can't remember a [ __ ] thing when we
watched love island this season
i couldn't like we turned on an episode
we literally stopped watching
days like a day before and i'm like so
what happened
i don't know wait why i don't know it's
like i'm kind of getting that too
it like freaks me the [ __ ] out like i
just can't i can't remember [ __ ] that i
watch
we uh that is i just feel like it's that
whole [ __ ] with your brain where
because the days like blur yeah i feel
like a movie in your mind it's not
different enough
yeah that it needs to restore it yeah
it's like oh it's just media like
oh he sat in front of the tv again
damn i don't know it's weird because
i've i've been thinking about this too a
little bit
it's just i can't remember [ __ ] i don't
like we've been watching that
series the boys on amazon is that good
it's actually great
you know for for what it is what i like
about amazon
is hbo has sex they use violence and i
love that just just
random violence it's so brutal i'm like
yeah
yeah yeah they give me this [ __ ] yeah
that's it that's that used to be
hbo a little bit didn't it i mean game
of thrones i guess but the vibe but like
the violence on amazon prime is like
jeff bezos fine
you know like what are we talking
billionaire violence
blow up a chimpanzee for a scene cause
[ __ ] it okay
damn yeah that actually happened i i
know like 20 percent
of the podcast listening around okay so
what what time is this
you said they blow up an animal well do
you remember the red wedding
um wasn't that pretty violent that was
like the classic or like one of the most
famous episodes of
game of thrones right am i [ __ ] crazy
right now the red wedding
um yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah right no this one what
happens
no this one is like comedic violence
like yeah yeah that's that's nice
yeah that's nice you don't get a lot of
that now no
no it was i don't want to spoil one part
because it's oh my good god it had me
hysterical okay
that's like the only scene in the last
like three months that i really remember
why is that i don't know it's because
it's also like the days are blurring
together too i'm having a hard time
remembering like just things in general
yeah leno's like last thursday like time
feels like it's going by way faster too
yeah yeah like this weird thing where
like at the beginning of quarantine we
were like oh by the summer it'll be
it'll be fine
like it was like this weird like july
and august yeah
and so we're kind of like biding our
time until then because that kind of
seemed
like this weird end date that we just
made up yeah in summer it'll be i'm sure
it'll be fine but
yeah and then like so the time flew
up until that point and then now it's
like happened already
yeah it's just i'm not even paying
attention to what it is anymore because
there's this weird like
nothing's normal and i don't know when
it's gonna you know what i'm saying yeah
no 100 we used to be the same year
every year it was like by the time we
get to okay we're going to do something
for halloween
for my birthday yeah and then i'm gonna
go home for christmas no it's just like
i don't know what the [ __ ] gonna
happen see ya yeah i'll see ya
and so it's just like day by day you
know yeah
it's been wild i mean it was it was good
to see you know
our boy our boy malone brown yeah yes
our boy malone brown poster malone brown
dude malone brown
yeah yeah we hung out with him on
thursday that was nice
yeah it was it was it was good to see
him i know damn
let's pick that name up yeah just name
drop well no
because i don't know i i it was the
first time that i've been
out yeah that was parting with someone i
haven't seen in a long time that was
wild and forever yeah like that felt
really good
yeah to like see people yeah just i
could [ __ ] see it
like no it was good to see everybody and
everyone was just like the same
yeah you know that that part was great
yeah
okay it was the exactly the same it's
like no time has passed yeah nice
but it felt like forever i feel like we
haven't seen them in decades
yeah yeah you know it's just the whole
the
man that was uh um
what when we we dipped out but you was
you were pretty [ __ ] up at that point
i don't yeah i just
i puked like 12 times when i got back to
the room
seriously i i don't even like
that was the first time in like years
yeah that i had to leave
a place because i because i was like
embarrassed because you were just so
like i went to the bathroom and i like i
i felt like i was like
like i felt like i just looked like an
idiot walking in the bathroom and cuz i
was like no you look totally fine yeah
as a as a third priority observer
you you looked fine okay even though i
had my shirt off
that was the only funny part is that i
went upstairs to eat some onion rings
and i come back downstairs
and you're shirtless playing beer pong
yeah
because i was like i was like feeling i
was like you know
he had his shirt off right and we're
playing beer pong against each other i'm
like i'm gonna be i'm gonna do that
i want to feel like that you know good
three-year-old like that
yeah exactly i want to do it i want to
play
we got down there and elena was like
take yourself i was like [ __ ] no
hell no so i don't know who's coming
through that door gotta get drunk enough
man
yeah anything's a possibility well bro i
was like dying laughing because when
that whole crowd showed up
like you were just it's like there's
like him and there's like you're the
dude
who also has a shirt off yeah that was
like that was hey exactly
that was your character it's like all
right there was yeah he was shirtless
and there's like this guy there
where'd him yeah take this by gone hey
you know you rocked with it for a while
did i really yeah good for me yeah yeah
you held on
i was as well i was joking to you i was
trying to like egg you want to like go
up to their group
and just stand in there shirtless and
then like
and then no i was trying to get you to
like using my stomach together yeah or
like just like
be inappropriate as [ __ ] me like it's
cold out isn't it
i'm trying to keep mine down
it's a lot harder with no shirt let me
tell you that dude granted though to my
defense their outfits were way more
absurd
than they were yeah that's the crazy
part is wait more absolutely they look
crazier than you
yeah dude shirtless yep and i was like
in veer phone you gotta dip right now
and then i feel you know you you could
have said that and someone would have
misunderstood him like dude
i have skull and you're like no no no i
look i got a dip so yeah
totally bro pack one in dude yeah yeah
stacking a dip that's what i needed
right there yeah that'll sober you up
so you could just feel the [ __ ] up all
the way through yeah like
into your nerves that's what you needed
and your lungs we were drinking
these sweet lemon drops which for some
reason is the drink of choice
i was crying laughing because he goes
let's get 12. i was like bro
who's drinking 12 and he's like what
happens when you want more
you got to wait for them to bring up
more i'm like okay that's smart you're
thinking ahead
and but you know i'm expecting the uh
and they come up and they're [ __ ]
goblets
they're like they're huge i mean there's
like three in one
yeah i couldn't yeah big boys and a lot
of sugar in those
it's like a sweet cocktail in in itself
because it's lemon juice
yeah you need a lot of sugar to make
that drinkable and then if the glasses
are
rimmed with sugar the whole thing is
like a sweet
you know a little bad boy's treat
yeah that's just a fly trap yeah
like it's literally a fruit fly trap it
is seriously
[Laughter]
yo what up me my boy we sipping fruit
fly traps right now
[ __ ] is sweet as [ __ ] we gotta add some
apple cider vinegar to this thing it's
gonna be crazy
yeah yeah nah i had i had four sips of
one
i said no way and then you know you know
you know me i just i put it down
somewhere
yeah i finished it yeah and then my
onion rings arrived and that was the
real
that's when i had my party that's when
you got high that's when i got high
it's like my shirt off oh
onion rings baby i'm not trying to get
ketchup on this shirt that's why i got
that was my excuse i don't want to get
ketchup on this shirt yeah it's like
those are your pants i don't want to get
on the pants either
i just had to go upstairs so i got
completely naked to eat my onion rings
[Laughter]
[Music]
suck these things off can you imagine
like a stranger walking in we're going
to post one of those parties
let's check this place out oh my gosh oh
my god he's like shirtless with some guy
let's go upstairs i wonder what's
upstairs man oh my gosh a naked guy
eating onion rings
you're like nothing nothing no no i just
stand there
just dancing with it swaying left and
right
y'all want one yeah i want one and i'm
just
the box is like it's like perfectly open
in front yeah
covering my my jewels but everything
else
toe naked y'all want one you sure
i could fling it to you watch them do
this trick
yeah yeah yeah just and then your ring
just goes
spitting from the side of the box
lands perfectly in somebody's mouth try
and throw it back like a [ __ ] like a
horse i'm like a horseshoe
y'all want to play horseshoe see that
sounds disgusting but if it was it was
matthew mcgiggles yeah
you